vous les avez sûrement déjà croisés sur
nos routes ces fameux car jaunes qui
assurent les liaisons interurbaines mais
beaucoup plus rares il se peut que vous
trouviez au volant de ces autobus non
pas un conducteur mais une conductrice
rosem est la seule femme de son
entreprise à exercer ce métier
rencontre
[Musique]
bon ben je vais prendre mon service avec
mon collègue donc ben directement la
gare routière pour commencer la journée
quoi direction saintjou voilà ok c'est
parti pour avoir quoi
comme un beau contact les gens avoir le
sourire
êre
patient ça demande beaucoup de trucs
quoi voilà vous AZ le contact avec les
gens oui oui ça me dérange pas
donc comme j'aime j'aime aussi être sur
la route donc voilà
quoi et vous voyez faire un autre métier
non honnêtement non c'est pour
arrêter directement il pense que le
chômage m assise quoi ah c'est ça ou
rien d'autre ouais ouais voilà quoi
c'est quoi c'est presque une passion
finalement oui ça devient une passion à
la à la don mais sinon ça il faut aimer
il faut aimer il
faut c'est pas dès le départ il viennent
avoir le permis
en disant oui on est le permis non c'est
pas c'est pas que ça il faut aimer
rouler il faut aimer avoir le contact
avec les personnes donc ben
[Musique]
voilà à 37 ans rosem conduit depuis plus
de 6 ans ses autocars aujourd'hui c'est
au volant de ce car jaune long de 13 m
que ce petit bout de femme va assurer la
liaison avec le sud de Lille
[Musique]
il y a pas de distinction nousci chez
nous dans dans dans le milieu du
transport il y a pas de distinction
homme femme donc elle a elle a le même
planning elle fait les mêmes services
elle a elle a les mêmes problématiques
que que que peuvent avoir les hommes
dans dans ce métierlà les mêmes
contraintes mais elle les assume comme
si comme si c'était c'était un homme
donc et c'est très c'est c'est
remarquable c'est c'est c'est
remarquable pour une femmejourd'hui
d'exercer ce métier
là est pareil que nous est pareil pas de
souci ouais conduit pareil donc d' est
comme une voiture madame un monsur PL
conduit presque pareil
donc sécurité AV toute façonç les
formations il dit il dit pour nous il
dit pour la dame il dit pour toute façon
les formations c'est pour les mix donc
pas de souci Ros la seule femme parmi
les tris conducteurs de la société pour
laquelle elle travaille mais pas de
jugement cette conductrice a pris ici
toute sa place super bien super bien
franchement super bien du moment on a
l'entend Le respect avant tout donc mes
collègu beaucoup
qu' un petit truc qui va pas et voilà
quoi P à les personnes qui sont
d'ailleurs dans mon entreprise surtout
au niveau des femmes que comme je suis
la seule essaie de revenir vers carun
quoi parce que je suis la seule donc
[Musique]
voilà